"And the CMA Award for Entertainer of the
Year goes to Taylor Swift."
"Taylor Swift."
What if your fairy tale dreams came true...
But you were still miserable?
Taylor, I'm really happy for you, Imma let
you finish.
The fame.
The boyfriends.
The songs about the boyfriends.
"Well, it starts out fun.
There's always gotta be, like, a little bit
of glimmer, like, of good, for a relationship
to go bad, for you to miss it."
This Christmas, experience love like you never
have before.
Through the eyes of a billionaire.
Starring...
Johnny Depp as John Mayer.
Sylar as Joe Jonas.
Jared Leto as Jake Gyllenhaal.
Kris Humphries as Taylor Lautner.
Rachel Bilson as Selena Gomez.
Emily Osment as rival, Carrie Underwood.
And in a comeback performance no one saw coming,
Kira as Taylor Swift.
A Deflowered Heart.
"The only time it's been an issues is when
I was, like, going through a really bad breakup
with a guy and he goes, 'You better not write
about this,' and I'm like, 'Oh, I won't.'"
"Did you?"
"Yes."